you would do like sort of uh undercover  work and you'd find out everything on an  umpire cheating on the wife gambling  whatever he was doing and then you get  up to bat and you turn to the umpire and  you'd say to the guy hey man how was  your road post the other night yeah a  cheating on your wife that made them  give you good calls right um it gave him  no option because fear does a lot to a  man so I just realized early that  umpires controlled my life so I just  eliminated any risk of them having any  control over my life one of them to call  strike and and I'd look back and say  really what was his spread last night  but but again everything I did was about  getting an edge